fabienne kocher bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
aujourd'hui au vu de l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire les mesures adoptées au
sein des établissements scolaires sont
elles excessives selon vous bonjour oui
tout à fait nous les pédiatres nous le
disons depuis le début le protocole
sanitaire qui est imposé dans les écoles
est tout à fait excessif pour les
enfants les enfants qui retournent à
l'école et dans l'ensemble des accueils
périscolaires centre aéré n'ont pas
besoin de respecter de distanciation
sociale pour les enfants les mesures
sanitaires à appliquer sont des mesures
simples qu'il faudra d'ailleurs
reconduire à la rentrée prochaine qui
consistent simplement on initie une
hygiène irréprochable des mains il faut
simplement se laver les mains
régulièrement ne pas se toucher le
visage mais pour le reste il faut
arrêter avec ces mesures excessives de
distanciation social de prise de
température à l'entrée à l'école nous le
savons nous avons maintenant
suffisamment d'études l'ensemble des
pays européens le 10 comme nous les
enfants ne sont pas la cible de ce virus
les enfants n'ont pas été atteints par
ce virus
ils sont peu contagieux à la fois entre
eux et pour les adultes
alors du coup quelles sont les
conséquences de ces mesures sur la santé
des enfants
ma nous le savons nous l'avons
suffisamment dit les enfants souffrent
davantage du confinement que lui
coronavirus les enfants sont restés chez
eux pendant plus de deux mois
l'école à la maison les enseignants ont
fait beaucoup beaucoup de travail on ne
peut que les féliciter pour cela mais
les parents n'en peuvent plus nous le
voyons nous
régulièrement dans nos consultations les
parents n'en peuvent plus d'associer
télétravail école à la maison il faut
voir aussi les cas particuliers certains
enfants sont ou peuvent peuvent
bénéficier d'un environnement tout à
fait favorables qui permet de faire
l'école à la maison nous nous voyons en
consultation des enfants qui ont des
difficultés scolaires des enfants qui
sont en situation de
handicap qui ont des pathologies
chroniques tous ces enfants n'ont pas
repris ni leurs soins de rééducation
ni le chemin de l'école et il est temps
qu'ils puissent retrouver aussi un
rythme il faut qu'il puisse savoir ce
rythme on se lève le matin on va à
l'école on retourne à la maison le soir
même s'il ne reste plus que 1 mois avant
les vacances scolaires cette reprise de
rythme est indispensable pour les
enfants on n'a jamais vu six mois sans
école moi je vois des enfants qui ont
pris cinq kilos avec le confinement des
enfants qui ne l'auront pas revu leurs
enseignants alors qu'ils changent
d'établissement alors plusieurs
associations parlent je cite de
maltraitance institutionnelle interne
assez fort finalement pourquoi ce choix
le terme peut effectivement paraître
fort mais nous avons vu des courriers
adressés à des parents dans lesquelles
il était dit que les enfants ne
pourraient pas être consolé ci tombait à
la récréation
comme si les enfants étaient des
pestiférés qu'on ne pouvait pas les
approcher
alors nous savons que les enfants ne
sont pas contagieux des directeurs
d'établissements qui ont dit à des
parents que on ne pourrait pas
s'approcher de l'enfant pour l'aider des
enfants qui ont des auxiliaires de vie
scolaire auquel on à dire qu'il ne
pouvait pas retourner à l'école parce
que la ds ne pouvait pas s'approcher de
l'enfance est effectivement maltraitant
du point de vue institutionnel nous
n'accusons par les directeurs d'école
les enseignants d'être maltraitant mais
c'est le protocole qui entraîne cette
maltraitance
alors pour vous pour conclure les
enfants pourraient dès lundi prochain
retourner à l'école un peu comme avant
avec un
nombre d'élèves non pas la moitié mais
la classe en totalité selon vous c'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire nous nous ce que
nous souhaitons et ce que nous attendons
c'est qu'effectivement tous les enfants
puissent retourner à l'école comme avant
qu'ils puissent retrouver leurs écoles
avant la rentrée avec des classes
silsilah la dimension de la classe le
permet des effectifs presque normaux
merci beaucoup fabienne kocher d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de l'association
française de pédiatrie ambulatoire